Guido Segal, Screenwriter, Journalist, Film
Critic, Instructor: The truth is over the
years I keep doing it and the fact that I keep
going back to it means that I actually care.
Film Courage: Guido you have a quote
on your Facebook I think it was from
an interview that you did and the quote
begins with “Make sure you want it?”
Guido: Yes.
Film Courage: I’m wondering can I continue? I'll
let you know more of what you said here if you
want me to remind you? So it's “Trust your own
talent and the singularity of your own voice.
Be careful who you listen to
and if this is what you want,
don't get easily discouraged.” What does that
mean “Make sure you want it,” that's fascinating.
Guido: Yeah so I know a lot of talented people
talented writers talented artists in general but
talent is only a part of the equation I feel like
in in this medium you know it's so competitive and
so tough and it's so hard to get people to care
your talent can only get you so far it's important
by the way you don't have to be talented I feel
like persistence and I'm not saying anything new
here but persistence is so much more important
or as important as talent so creativity I feel
like you can develop it right you don't
have to be born creative you can nurture it
but there's a part of you that has has to hustle
so what you can't fake it if you don't want it
and this applies to actors directors writers
people can tell if you desire it and if you
don't that's totally fine and I'm not gonna
tell people what line of work they should be in
but you can sense when someone really wants to
tell a story when someone wants to because writing
is not necessarily easy it's whoever tells
you writing is easy you know I suspect that
statement I'm not saying it's the hardest thing
their hardest jobs for sure but there's something
about writing that's exhausting because it's
you know it involves an emotional introspection
trying to figure out who you are what do you
want to talk about what resonates with you
what resonates with other people so it is
draining that's why you know I can only
write a certain amount of pages a day because
I want to write something that's truthful and
writing truthful pages takes a lot of energy a
lot of thought a lot of asking questions a lot
of doubt that's why you know I didn't mean
that quote to be daunting what I mean is
if you really want to do this then no one can
stop you just you know there can be failure
along the way that there can be many frustrations
I mean daily every writer will know this you know
some days you just write great pages some days
it doesn't work some days you write bad or bad
pages or you get rejections or you get awful notes
you know notes that you don't know what to do with
like how am I going to apply this note and it's
a job you can't say no right so what I meant is
you know if the desire is there if the flame is
within you then you got the most important thing.
Film Courage: How should someone quote
unquote check themselves to know if they
really want it because I think we all think
we want certain things and then once we
go through the process day in and day out then
it becomes clear to us what it actually is
yeah I it's a good question so I don't I don't
intend to be a guru of any sorts and sometimes
the line is a bit blurry between like self-help
and you know but it is a very intimate thing
you know to me at least writing is a very
intimate thing very personal thing even if
I'm not writing about my own life which I rarely
do it is incredibly personal I care about it
and you know there are moments of doubt of course
there were moments and there are still moments
when I wonder is this the best way to channel
my abilities my skills my talent the truth is
over the years I keep doing it and the fact that
I keep going back to it means that I actually care
that to me is the the best evidence that I am a
writer this is not a hobby this is not something
that I'm good at I mean I'm good at certain
things that I don't necessarily spend time on
I don't know I guess I could have been a good
lawyer I've thought about this many times I
would have certainly made more money I would have
been more stable my dad would have been delighted
but that's not how it went you know there's a
creative energy there's a need to express yourself
through stories because I mean I've i've been a
film critic for 10 years before actually becoming
a screenwriter and you know that's that's a long
story how I became a film critic I don't think any
child you know any eight ten-year-old child says I
want to become a film critic right but it happened
and I'm i'm glad it did but you know being a
journalist or writing a film analysis which I did
that's not that's a whole different approach
it's still writing but it's not I mean it is
creative but it's it's it's not the same
way to apply your your emotion your brain
it's very different so at some point I had to
question myself you know do I want to analyze
a film that's already made and out there someone
else's work or do I want to produce my own work
and that takes courage and that takes facing
your fears and limitations and you know it's
it's really hard to write a script if you were an
attorney presenting your own case so you were you
were employed by guido segal and you were speaking
to the jury about why guido should continue
on this path so ladies and gentlemen of the jury
I present to you my client and and he really wants
this he's not sure if it'll ever pan out or I
don't know what would what would the argument be
how would you convince 12 jurors with their
arms crossed that I guess what I would say
is I like a good challenge and this is the most
challenging and exciting thing that I've found
I don't I don't know if I could have been a
doctor in the sense that I couldn't do the
same thing over and over and over and over again
and with writing it's always new no script is
or play I guess or novel they're never the same
so with practice you get better at it but every
new story you face or you know you have to
break down poses new a new set of new challenges
and that to me is very exciting so persistence
we're going back to what you said originally that
talent necessarily it's not always in the equation
it's persistence yeah I mean and especially in a
city like l.a there's so many talented people
and I don't say this you know lightly I mean
I've met so many talented writers that come
from all over the country all over the world
and they're here for a reason
but to make it here I mean I'm
again I don't want to be the one
saying what it means to make it
I would say to get a job or to have a several jobs
that just just to be paid to write means a lot
I want to be very realistic of course you need
a dream we all have one or many dreams but
I think my goal is to keep to be paid to write and
that to me is the dream it's so maybe I've become
older and jaded and more realistic but it's
so hard to get paid to write to get paid to be
an artist a creative so you have to constantly
negotiate with what the industry wants and the
standards and what you want and it's not
necessarily the same of course when you
get to a guess to a certain point in your career
that you're in control you can decide but still I
mean I remember I met paul feig right we did wrote
and directed bridesmaids among ghostbusters among
many other things and I asked him paul when
is the right time to do your passion project
and he said never never is the right time and you
just do it if you want but know that it's risky
when you were in grade school or as a teenager
were you bored in school no I actually you know
I get I was I was a nerd I was very I wasn't
a troublemaker I actually loved loved school
I know that's not a common thing to say
but I loved learning I loved history
I did okay with math and physics and chemistry
you know all those subjects but literature history
later on philosophy like I connected to all that
you know and I love I've always loved reading
I guess when I decided to be a filmmaker
you know and I still dream about directing
I don't know I don't think I'm a director
by nature because I love words I work with
words and that's why since I love films and
I love literature I'm a writer I mean and it
makes so much sense for me to be a screenwriter
but no I mean I actually love school
and grad school and you know college
was the passion project ever the right time did
you find time to make yours or it's still in
the works well you know I had a tv I have a tv
show that I've developed that I've written the
pilot and it's been in development for three years
and it's period I mean and again I don't make it
easy on myself you know it's it's an expensive
show it's period it's about the 60’s Chicago
sorry to interrupt I won't by the way this is the
thing I didn't set out to be a period writer but
I guess it's it resonates with me so I wrote one
show that takes place in the late 60’s in Chicago
that I don't think that's going to happen by the
way because they they're going to make the movie
I think it's about the young lords and of course
you know me not being puerto rican doesn't help
I got very I met some of those historical figures
I interviewed them it was really interesting but
sometimes some things don't pan out and you
just let them go and that's you know this
show no the show is is takes place mostly
in Boston in the 60s so it's psychedelics
and you just gotta be patient you know I've
written that script so many times and rewritten it
and you know it takes time and money and getting
people attached this is about Timothy Leary yes
it is okay I as growing up in San Francisco knew
his name a lot and around interest yeah so that's
I adapted this author who now became my friend
Robert Greenfield and bob wrote about all these
figures in the 60s like you know The Grateful Dead
Jerry Garcia and the Grateful Dead, Timothy Leary
so I adapted bob and we became friends and he's
like a mentor to me now so that opened up that
script opened up other doors to writing about you
know the 60s and rock and roll and psychedelics
and and I clearly connect even though I wasn't
born around that time I connect to that I felt
the same way even though I'm a Gen X-er or so
yeah but there was something about being there
and just seeing just the counterculture
movement that was very attractive and
yeah you know I what I suspect or what I feel at
least is that we have an idea of those of those
times and a feeling that there was a dream of
how society could have been and that it didn't
work out but for you know for a few years it felt
like America at least could become place where you
know there was a certain amount of freedom and and
people were against the Vietnam war and you know
expansion of consciousness and and I feel like a
lot of what's happening today is still you know
is the the the effect of those of those days like
we're still we're going back to some of the ideas
and theories back in the day I you know I'm
seduced by the idea of of a different society
where everyone's welcome and you know you have
a certain amount of freedom to do what you do as
long as you don't hurt other people I guess that's
why I go back to the 60s or my idea of the 60s and
is that one of the reasons you said you don't make
it easy on yourself in that doing you know doing
the time different you know in terms of costumes
and cars and and getting the rights to music and
things like that would be a lot certainly I mean
period by itself you can see producers get scared
because we're talk if it's a tv show we're talking
about at least a 2 million dollar episode in a ten
episode season at least I'm saying right so it's
costumes it's cars if it's based on real people
it's having vip which which I do but you know
it's more challenging so I get this note or this
comment constantly which is why don't you write
something contemporary based on your own story
and I usually reply to this you know there is a
lot of me in what you read the fact that it's not
autobiographical doesn't mean it's not incredibly
personal I mean I have I have been trying this is
the thing I mean this it's everyone has their
own approach I don't like to write about myself
explicitly I don't feel like it's necessary but
everyone's free to do whatever they feel I mean
sure I mean I incorporate parts of
my life and anecdotes into my writing
but I give it to someone else
and then that's my approach.
How bad do you really want it?